Peaceful rise,
that is to say China's goal is to work
out the enormous internal contradictions
of the country,
the growth,
tremendous growth of wealth in urban
areas,
tremendous impoverishment and immobility
and rural areas and the fear of the
political explosion that could cause
China's goal was to work that stuff out
in a quiet setting as possible.
They don't want to cause international
upset.
They don't want to get into public
fights with the United States or anybody
else for that matter.
Nevertheless,
their political values are profoundly
different from ours.
I don't think we can have much
expectation of China changing China's
internal political culture.
What I think is a really complicated
challenge though,
is that China,
much more than Russia,
has a kind of exportable model.
That is to say they too have something
to promote,
but it's not democracy.
It's it's capitalist,
it's autocratic capitalism.
Russia doesn't feel that way because it
doesn't seem to have a system.
Where they have is a lot of oil which
just keeps their coffers refilled.
China has no such an inherent advantage.
China has figured out a means of
economic and social and political
organization whereby they can be an
incredible economic dynamo,
but keep a lid on politically.
Now,
this is of course a tremendously
appealing model.
If you're an autocrat in some
impoverished third world country and
China goes around the world,
especially to resource rich countries
and and offers to kind of deal,
you allow us to have a lock on your oil,
a certain amount of your oil,
so we have a guaranteed amount at a
guaranteed price.
We in turn will give you concessional
loans and grants.
You in turn will use those funds,
turn around and pay Chinese construction
and engineering companies to build your
infrastructure.
It's a great deal from the point of view
of the recipient countries.
The only problem is that it cements in
place these authoritarian political
structures,
and so that's a problem for the west,
not just for the United States,
for other donors,
for institutions like the World Bank and
the IMF.
How do we come up with a sufficiently
appealing,
countable,
and that's an ongoing problem.